first of all congratulations on this
first big acting role
i mean obviously
she made it i know right i care i do i i
honestly it is so crazy too because you
know you hear actors in interviews
always say like you know we we
shot this three years ago and i was like
no i actually like forgot i was like oh
wait i actually have a movie that i did
like
um it was such a cool process and it's
really cool and i got to see the
screener and i i just had a total moment
i'm like i'm so richly blessed thank you
god it's been really cool please tell me
you are calling me after the most
intense sex of your life hard to have
sex when you've been catfished but you
won't believe what happened you're
telling me the guy exists and he's there
you should totally go for it why i
actually screened it i watched it i was
like heather yeah you know because you
you can't believe girl you bring a lot
of comedy
they knew what they were doing when they
hired you you know they did you're
either gonna laugh or you're like i'm
either gonna be so funny you're laughing
or you're like i feel sorry for her
we're gonna cry so at least in this
movie it's it bill joe you know well now
i'm curious what does your mom robin
think about you being a big movie star
oh i mean honestly she has yelled at me
like three times a day because i still
live at home with her so while everybody
else goes like their mansion in the
hollywood hills i'm in my mom's basement
right now so stay humble okay just like
in the movie just like in the movie
that's kind of amazing uh you know i i
told you a lot of people at et were
excited that i was talking to you i was
like well then send me some questions
one question i got was has rigatoni seen
the film
tony has seen the film and he snored uh
all the way through it but yeah but that
is what happens when a french bulldog
does zoomies he has about 10 minutes of
energy in him and then it snaps the rest
of that time yeah yeah yeah like mom i
saw you you did good i gotta go sleep i
gotta go yeah i love it
well obviously in the movie natalie is
uh really swiping through her share of
riffraff on the dating app uh you're of
course married now but like did you ever
experience the dating apps what are your
feelings about those things generally
i have been with my husband i mean we've
only been married a couple months but
we've been together years um so when i
the only time i really had any like uh i
ever went through the apps i did like
early on like match.com and i mean that
was in the early early stages and that
but i gotta be honest with you i live
vicariously through all my single
friends and i get very aggressive like
they'll get off the app for a couple
days and then i'm i'll have a couple
cocktails and i'm literally calling my
husband like i'm on i'm on bumble for
like you know my girlfriend natalie
right now and i'm just swiping through
because it's like i gotta have some fun
too you know absolutely because it is
sometimes it feels like a game for us
singles it's like
you know we're just killing time at this
point
and then some of my girlfriends are like
heather you why did you accept all of
these men like they're not my type
and i forget i'm like oh right that's
right i was shopping for you not me yeah
what tips do you give them or really any
single people uh when it comes to
navigating online dating what advice do
you have listen i think everybody has a
type physically like you know
what you're into so i think go for that
but also listen i'm a comedian if i got
back on the apps like if anybody ever
had to look on my instagram they would
go running in the other direction
because they'd be like she's a liability
like she's insane but i think it's like
go with your gut right and then and then
on the other side of that you got to
give some people a chance you know i
i think you got to give some people a
chance and then just go for it as long
as you feel safe i say you know branch
out and go for it have you heard of
anyone using your images to catfish
people on these apps or anything
no but if it works by all means tell me
yeah you're welcome i'm fabulous so i
want your help i want to come up with a
dating profile bio for your characters
actually heather so think about or at
least maybe something that would be for
sure included in their bio so let's
start with margie mcdaniels because you
know what margin is too much let's get
going babies what would be in her dating
app profile
margie you know she's a little road hard
put away wet so she works at costco so
her profile would be like um
loves costco
you know uh sausages more sausages and
do you have sausage xoxo margie
mcdaniels like that's it where she likes
to grill but also there's a little
sexual innuendo i was gonna say there's
a double thing there a double meaning
yeah yeah okay and if you don't have a
and if you don't have a costco card she
will not date you so
what would be on brenda carlisle's
dating app bio we're at the one more of
villains and resorts i've met some
friends from new york i'm gonna go down
their waterslide and see if they have
any tequila oh well brenda carlisle is
mississippi's number one real estate
agent so it would be something like oh
you know i'm all enough that abc's
always be closing um and maybe you know
it would have to be something about
making a deal closing a deal i'm just
trying to close a deal whether it's on a
townhouse in new mexico or if it's on
love
these women love their innuendos i think
they do
it's very fitting all right how about in
a garden it's your favorite gal from
east hampton the barefoot contessa ina
garden not to be confused with a
barefoot contessa in a garden
get in a barefoot i'm just walking
around anyways ah what would be on her
date
ida gardens would just be like i'm rich
hope you are too that's it
you know what she makes a mean cocktail
and they're also giant so i hope there's
a photo of her you know cosmos oh yeah
she'd be on the cosmos she'd show you
the perfect roast chicken but it would
say in her profile just like i'm very
wealthy you better be too and then like
with the cutest smile right yeah exactly
yeah okay now if you were single heather
mcmahon what would be on your dating
profile just just uh help 9-1-1
[Laughter]
you know i mean my husband and i joke
about that all the time because like
he's got single friends and he sees what
they're going through
in the dating i think it would just be
like
um
hmm what would mine actually say i like
red wine i like the spinach dip um and
you love them
i love a meze and don't judge me from my
instagram that's what i would say
are you kidding your instagram is gold i
would i would link that to the the
profile maybe okay i see it i'm just
saying that's how much i love you um now
speaking of your hubby are there any
updates on the italian nuptials with
your italian stallion
i'll tell you what you know we got
legally married at the courthouse last
year because our accountant told us we
had to do that um
but it's kind of like the wedding that
we've been planning for years but who
knows if it'll happen we just went to
italy to replan but the funny thing is
people ask all the time like heather if
you're already legally married like why
spend the money i'm like listen i'm
married to an italian if you think
you're gonna put a deposit somewhere in
italy and get your money back you're not
going to so regardless we're throwing a
party so hopefully it'll be next summer
berger loins who knows
i think it'll happen i feel like you'd
be doing yourself a disservice if you
didn't throw a party to celebrate this
it's a huge deal too and i mean listen
i'm ready to like wear the white wedding
dress like i thought you were in a
courthouse in sequins but i am ready to
like be a bridezilla i feel like the
whole thing i have been there for all of
my friends and i and while they've been
monsters so let me be a monster for like
a month you know you want the wedding
party you want the bridesmaids the whole
thing i don't want the bridesmaids and i
don't want any of that because i don't
want anybody to look thinner than me so
i'm not allowed i'm not allowing anybody
to stand next to me but i do want to
have the dramatic like six costume
changes it has to be all about me yeah i
think you should probably get the
princess diana train you know like just
a fabric yeah yeah yeah exactly well you
know there's a lot of life happening
around you your bff jennifer lawrence is
expecting her first child which is
amazing
what is what gift does heather mcmahon
get jennifer lawrence for her baby
shower
i gotta be honest with you i've been
panicking about it um you know what the
thing is she has such a great sense of
humor and listen we're new friends like
i'm just i i'm so grateful to have her
in my life because she's a doll but it's
got to be something funny like you get
something for the baby but then you have
to get something really really like
smart and funny for her and it may just
be like a box set of every housewife
episode ever because she's the biggest
fan um but yeah it's more of a gift for
her less for the baby you know what i
mean i bet she's jonesing to go out with
you for martini once this baby's out
right listen i'm jonesing to go out with
martini with any new moms let's go
what kind of mom do you think jayla will
be
um i think i think she'll be a fun mom i
think she's adventurous
uh oh god what kind of mom should be a
fun mom a good one you know yeah i mean
you know just
i listen i think all of my friends who
are now starting to have kids we're all
just trying to figure it out there is no
manual you know i'm like if you didn't
leave the baby on the roof you know
leaving the grocery store you're doing a
great job yeah
i love that well speaking of famous
friends i gotta know what was golfing
with rick ross like
well i'll tell you what he is such a gem
he's the most warm loving person ever
and um a terrible golfer like an
absolutely
awful golfer but that's okay he's new to
the sport and i say golf is one of those
things you have to give it time and he
just wanted to have a cocktail and so
did i so we hit a couple holes and then
we hit the bar oh he just wanted to kick
it yeah yeah yeah i love it i love it so
i'm dying to know what is next for you
um are there still plans to develop a
comedy series about your life story
yeah so um i've got a show in
development at peacock we're waiting
fingers crossed you know hollywood is
you gotta wait for somebody to call you
to show up on set um
yeah and i'm working on a comedy special
and you know touring all through next
year we're about to announce in a couple
weeks all the new spring dates for the
farewell tour so it feels honestly
really good to be back on the road and
to be in front of live audiences again
and to giggle i just love being able to
create stuff on stage and i'm just so
honored and honestly thrilled that
people come out to the shows it's so
cool i'm curious do you have a short
list of people who are thinking to play
you in this peacock series
i'm playing myself yeah
yeah here's the thing my mom thinks that
she's gonna play herself and i've told
her so many times i'm like mom i love
you to death but this would be a
conflict of interest we would kill each
other on set so i'm gonna i'm gonna
catch somebody to play like my sister
but i'm i'm playing a heightened version
of myself but thank god okay
people ask me sometimes you're like
heather if they ever like later years
down the road like they ever did like a
biopic of you like who would play you
i'm like i don't care if i'm dead stuff
me like weekend at bernie's it will be
me and somebody who's a like you know
ventriloquist my mouth because i will
never allow anybody to play me but me
you know what we're going to hold you to
that yeah yeah
you know speaking of your family so many
fans have been saying that you and your
family need a reality show we're just
gonna touch these up right here i can't
believe she's letting me do this don't
miss the spot heather make sure you
cover it all right okay the bossiest
client i've ever had is that something
you guys have either been offered or
something you'd be interested in okay i
gotta be honest with you we haven't
offered reality shows but i feel like
nowadays if you get on reality you
either get audited by the irs or you end
up in jail or divorced so i'm just
trying to keep a low profile and control
the comedy world but um i do think it
would be it'd be chef's kiss tv i
respect that though what about a um what
about a travel show i know that's
something you've lobbied for as well
i gotta be honest with you that would be
such a dream because for me like even
just touring i've gotten to see the
world and see you know especially the
country but um i feel like there's not
enough women in travel you know and
you've got these amazing men and chef
driven shows where they're these male
chefs who are doing it but it's like i
want to watch a travel show where i go
somewhere and as a woman you're like
this is where to get a seven dollar
blowout you know what i mean yes yes oh
my god we need that show we need that
yeah listen i have naturally curly hair
the boys need the blowouts too and if
you're in vietnam why not find you know
the good spot like i was just there and
i was telling i was in vietnam before to
be endemic and i was like telling
everybody like this is where to get a
you know 10 blowout and go here for a
massage there can be beauty and
lifestyle elements to it too so who
knows maybe we'll pitch it oh my god he
is so cute really there's only one con
what
you've never seen him congratulations on
love heart it is such a girl i hope
everybody checks it out it's a really
fun cute like just movie and i had so
much fun making it and you know hey look
at us we're on netflix
[Music]